many of us know award-winning after
Damian Lewis as a cutthroat hedge fund
manager Bobby Axelrod and the hit TV
show billions in the new season he finds
himself on the same team listen to this
as his one-time nemesis former US
Attorney Chuck Rhodes who's portrayed by
Paul Giamatti how is that possible
Rose was asked to investigate the
administrator of the police pension fund
so answer this what happens to you if I
take down Raul Gomez
I prefer that didn't happen and I
appreciate the gesture of you coming
here to ask but we can't just leave it
there because as I said you've been
tasked I have
is there some other way to satisfy your
taskmaster on this he seems to feel that
Raul is using the pension fund the way
Chris Stapleton uses Tennessee whiskey
just like his thirst he's not not in the
way your man thinks he is no way your
way your man thinks he is billions is on
show time which by the way is a division
of CBS we welcome Damian Lewis back to
the table I'm with be on it where is
that a part I want to live there
how specific should I be this is the
thing about this show number one they're
working together and there are really it
seems no good guys on this show anymore
which is also makes it fascinating to
watch I think yeah you know good guys
anymore Oh God are there any good guys
anymore this is a is this this is the
broader commentary on what's going on at
the moment yeah sure Deena there was
always a cowboy and sheriff story and
the sheriff is is now in cahoots with
the cowboy you know billions what the
guys always wanted I think to portray as
a transactional yes favor trading world
which i think is probably quite new
yorky but we're seeing it everywhere now
it's permeated politics entirely and
yeah you scratch my back I'll scratch
yours let's not worry too much about how
we get it done but let's get it done
everything is transactional right in to
ski ski passes yes everything every
little thing is Finnegan's passion yes
yeah are you are you enjoying being
being friends with mr. G or allies I
should say with mr. Giamatti now rather
than adversaries he's the easiest man to
be a friend with in real life he's we
love each other we get on very well and
we love our scenes early on in the
series season one and two there was
always such expectation when we came
together yes it was like we got a we got
a sort of like tough our chests out and
it was like let's out Stanislavski each
other I sort of like reach across the
scene to each other and and actually it
will calm down a bit and that's actually
really nice that we we can actually just
play with each other a little bit and
you know we'll see how long they remain
friends yeah when it can be neither
leave their friends information was like
a friend of anyone when there's
something yeah that's right
I love in this I love in the first
episode of season four you have at you
oven you have a new adversary in John
Malkovich who's a question oligarch and
you you say your character says for the
first time I think this guy may be
willing to do things that I wouldn't do
yeah it's like you had worse than you
that's what the Russians that's good you
know that
yeah well that whole Russian storyline
as well is very current obviously I
think that's been good for Bobby
actually he doesn't I enjoy not having
to be the kingpin the whole time I quite
like there's a hierarchy and he has to
manipulate and maneuver around some
obstacles and certainly you know Gregor
and Allah provides presents a big
obstacle if you've played these
quintessential American characters and
for me you'll always be Brody and I
remember the first time I heard you talk
I was like mind blown like what he has
the accent how do you nail this American
accent so effortless effortlessly I I
don't I don't know it's a bit of luck I
think I was at training I well certainly
had dialect lessons you know the first
time I did it was on Band of Brothers
when I great and dick winters and I had
a lot of dialect coaching for that
otherwise I just I've I hear it I hear I
hear it I feel comfortable with it I
have I came to America a little bit as a
kid my I have cousins who live in
Connecticut we said come and see them
and you know but Brits always seem to be
able to nail the American accent and
Americans never get the British
attention I don't think that's that's
true these are pretty good to some
pretty good but you know renamed Gwyneth
they'll they were all day that's good no
you're right I want to talk about
homeland for a second because I actually
don't see Brody anymore and I I was such
a big fan of homeland I thought how
could I get past that character but I
think you've done it so well that I
don't say OD anymore so I wondered when
you did when you were finished with
homeland were you worried about you
would be typecast that way or I know
it's called acting I know that no no no
but you don't you you never you can
never underestimate as an actor the
effect that your your characters have
visit people in their Lee
rooms and you go there weekly and people
sit down and then they talk about you
the next day I think that can be
confusing for an actor sometimes it's
great well now I'm going to go play King
Lear or you know now I'll go play you
know a comedy clown there was an we can
do that because you're Brody and so you
I think you have to fight hard and be
conscious of that yeah and I'm very
pleased to hear that you don't see Brody
Louis thank you so much for being here
this morning billions there Sunday's on
Showtime it's terrific